Steve also stars in welcome tomorrow in
which marks his big screen reunion with
his 40 year old virgin co-star Leslie
Mann we fell in love with you guys
together 40 old virgin in that she's
throwing up in a car right and on me and
on you that's literally what it's been
13 years since friends Steve and Leslie
went on that wild messy ride I think we
shot it over the course of like four
days it was a lot I remember he had so
much fun doing it
to be continued now they're reunited in
the emotional drama welcome to Marwin
steve plays mark hogan camp who in real
life was the victim of a horrific
assault during his long recovery mark
began creating his own imaginative world
of toys turning himself into an action
figure
you know everybody's dressed in these
gray onesies and you're out with these
sensors acting and we make for you to
wear a onesie it's fantastic I kind of
just wanted to live in it
Leslie Janelle Monae Diane Kruger and
Game of Thrones Gwendoline Christie play
Marx living dolls
oh they're his protectors they're the
person who found him left for dead the
people in nursing back to health is your
wife your protector definitely yeah I
remember when we were getting married
and I was super nervous and we were
getting married back in Massachusetts
and it's 105 degrees out and the church
didn't have air-conditioning
I was sweating buckets and I saw her
coming down and I'll never forget it I
instantly stopped sweating and I was
like that person has my back I never
really made this connection before with
wanting to do this movie too because
when I saw her coming down the aisle to
get married I thought I'm so much more
powerful now that she is a part of my
world
[Music]